today we're going to be talking about
the reaction quotient Q in this video
I'm going to go over how you calculate Q
and how you use it we're going to start
with an example reaction between sulfur
dioxide so2 gas which will react with
oxygen gas and this is a reversible
reaction that makes sulfur trioxide or
so3 we should make sure this is a
balanced reaction we have two sulfur
dioxides reacting with 1:02
to give to so3 at equilibrium we can
calculate the equilibrium constant k c
so at equilibrium we know the
concentrations should be constant
because the rate of the forward and
backward reactions are the same and if
we plug those concentrations in to this
expression we will get KC so KC is the
product concentration raised to the
second power so that's from this
stoichiometric coefficient and then our
reactant concentrations so so2 squared
and the concentration of o2 so we know
at some temperature if you plug in the
equilibrium concentrations KC is equal
to four point three but what if we're
interested in looking at the reaction
and it's not an equilibrium yet or maybe
we just don't know if it's it
equilibrium in that case when you're not
sure it's at equilibrium or really at
any point in your reaction or anytime we
can calculate the reaction quotient Q so
Q C is equal to the concentration of our
product squared so the concentration of
the product raised to the stoichiometric
coefficient times the reactant
concentrations also raised to their
stoichiometric coefficients so so2
squared and
- so you might be wondering at this
point what's the difference the equation
for QC and KC
will always look exactly the same and
the main difference is when you use them
the equilibrium constant K you calculate
only with the equilibrium concentrations
so the C means everything is in terms of
the molar concentration and for a
reaction quotient Q again everything is
in terms of molar concentration but we
can calculate it with any concentrations
and we don't have to be at equilibrium
molar concentration so let's calculate
this for a set of example concentrations
at some point in our reaction we have
the following concentrations we have
zero point 100 leur so2
zero point three Oh Mulder Oh two and
three point five molar of our product so
if we plug these numbers into our
expression for QC we get three point
five molar squared in the numerator and
zero point one Oh square times zero
point three in the denominator so if I
plug this into my calculator I get that
QC with this set of concentrations is
four thousand and eighty three so now we
know how to calculate QC so next we're
going to talk about what it tells you so
there are three possible scenarios so in
Q is equal decay that tells us we're at
equilibrium so if at any point you're
not sure if your concentrations are
there e are the equilibrium
concentrations you can calculate Q and
check if it's equal to K and in this
case it's not so the other two
possibilities are that Q is greater than
K which is the case here or Q can be
less than K
so let's go through both of those
possibilities we can draw all the
possible values of Q on a number line or
a Q line so Q can have values anywhere
from 0 to infinity when you have no
product your numerator is 0 and Q is
equal to 0 so that tells us Q equals 0
when you have all reactants and no
products and then if you have no
reactants left and all products we have
0 in the denominator and that gives us a
Q value of infinity so that means at Q
equals infinity we have all products and
then we have a bunch of values in
between and I'm going to just write some
intermediate values in here but the
actual intermediate values here aren't
super important we're mostly going to
want to compare the relative values of
our Q and K so Q here is equal to 4,000
83 which I will place right around here
so that's QC and our K and yellow is 4.3
so we'll place that right around here so
we can see that our Q is larger than K
and it's closer to having all products
at the concentrations we have up here we
have way more products and we should at
equilibrium so our reaction is going to
try to adjust the concentrations to get
T equilibrium and what that means in
terms of our number line is that our
concentrations are going to shift so
that Q can get closer to K since our
shift is to the right and it's moving
towards all reactants our reaction is
going to favor reactants to get to
equilibrium so when Q is greater than K
like here we're going to favor reactants
reactance and then the last scenario
when Q is less than K our reaction will
favor products and we can show that also
on our number line if we had a different
set of concentrations where Q was less
than K which I will show using this
color here if we had say a Q value
around here then our shift would be to
the right towards making more products
and therefore that would mean our
reaction is going to try to reach
equilibrium by favoring the forward
reaction so that's how you calculate Q
and how you use it to see how the
reaction concentrations will shift to
get to equilibrium in our next video
we'll go over an example problem using Q
and trying to figure out how the
reactant concentrations will shift for
another reaction